Speaker 1: There has been speculation and
questions as to whether Joe Biden will run
for reelection in 2024.
Now you already you may know my position on
this already, and my position on this is that
I see a Joe Biden reelection as a very tough
uphill battle, and I see a Kamala Harris replacement
of Joe Biden as the Democratic nominee in
2024 as a very tough uphill battle.
Now sometimes people will write to me and
they'll say, David, are you saying that so
that people don't rest on their laurels and
tune out?
Or are you saying that?
Are you overstating that or I'm not gaming
anything.
I am just giving my honest opinion, my genuine
opinion.
It doesn't mean I have someone I think would
do.
I have no, I have.
There's no superstar right now in the Democratic
Party that I love and I feel super inspired
by.
I don't have any better alternatives at this
point to Biden and Harris.
I'm just saying I see the reelection hill
as a very steep one for both Joe Biden and
Kamala Harris.
The White House has put out a statement saying
Joe Biden intends to run in 2024, and this
created so many headlines of people saying
he's running.
He's running.
And I think you have to understand that there
is one important word in this headline and
that word is intense.
It is intense.
And what one intends to do in 2021, 10 months
into their presidency can have absolutely
no connection whatsoever to what one actually
does in 2024.
CNN summarizing the article, saying the White
House said on Monday that Joe Biden intends
to run for reelection in 2024, following a
recent report indicating that the commander
in chief and staff are attempting to assuage
concerns about his future political prospects.
When White House press secretary Jen Psaki
was asked aboard Air Force One whether she
could confirm if he was going to run in 2024
and whether he was telling staff that she
responded Yes, that's his intention.
The Washington Post reported Biden and members
of his inner circle have been telling.
Allies, he plans to run again and attempt
to address concerns about whether he could
commit to another presidential campaign given
his age.
A recent Quinnipiac poll showed Biden's approval
rating sits at 36 percent now.
Very important to remember that if you actually
look at the FiveThirtyEight Biden approval,
it's actually not much changed from where
it was.
It's still at 43 percent and it's been there
basically going all the way back to a month
ago.
So although it is true that there is a Quinnipiac
poll showing Biden at 36, on average, there's
been no movement for a month or maybe even
like five or six weeks.
That doesn't mean Biden's approval rating
is particularly good right now.
But the 36 percent number is very much an
outlier, so this entire story is about the
word intense.
Intense can have a very different meaning
if things change or if whatever happens.
If you said today, David, sir, even money
bet no odds, just if you all you have to bet
on is, does Biden run or does Biden not run?
I would take the even money bet on Biden does
not run for reelection.
It's not by much.
Right now, I would say I'm.
55, 45, maybe 60, 40 that Joe Biden does not
run for reelection in 2024.
We don't know, too.
I know people were right, will write in and
say, David, you're wrong.
It's an odds prediction for which a marginally
feel more confident that Biden doesn't run.
It's not like a big claim.
I'm not saying that it's a statement of fact.
It's a statement of opinion because it's in
the future.
And I'm saying 55, 45 or 60 40, I want to
hear from you really about two questions.
Question one is and you can you can let me
know on Twitter at David Pakman.
Question one is, will he run?
What do you think?
Question two.
Maybe the more important question is if he
runs.
What exactly is the path to reelection?
Because I see it as a very, very tough, particularly
when the out party tends to have higher enthusiasm.
We have this cult of Q Slash Trump, which
is still very, very strong.
And I think, I mean, listen to there a lot
of the motivation for voting Biden in 2020.
Was to get rid of Donald Trump, that was a
worthy motivation.
I'm not.
That was my motivation.
Among other things, we had to get rid of Trump.
With Trump gone, the early signs are it is
tougher to get Democratic voters motivated.
And so I am worried about Biden's path to
victory in 2024 if he's the candidate.
Of course, if he's better than the alternative,
we don't know who that will be.
That might be Trump might be someone else.
I will say we've got to vote for Biden again.
I'm still as pragmatic as ever.
But I'm curious to hear from you.
Find me on Twitter at De Packman.
We'll take a quick break and continue getting
caught up from the long holiday weekend right
after this short break.
I want to remind everybody that on December
14th, we've scheduled the next David Pakman
Show Viewer Town Hall, the first one was incredible.
I think we had hundreds of people called in.
We took close to, I think, a hundred different
questions and comments from audience members.
It will be six p.m. Eastern Time, 3:00 p.m.
Pacific on December 14th.
It will stream live if you want to watch it
on the Pacman Live YouTube channel.
That's our second YouTube channel.
You can find it at youtube.com.
Slash Pacman Live.
Everybody is welcome to call in, but we will
give priority on the call line to our website
members.
Grab a membership at Join Pacman dot com.
Not only will you get priority on our town
hall, you will also get a daily bonus show.
You will get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show and so many other great
things.
So sign up today.
Join Pacman dot com!